[Music]
in careful what you tweet news Oh
submitted by thankful for the JK fam
thank you guys
the New York Times [ __ ] up for its news
hire despite the internet finding her
old racist tweets oh good for you New
York time oh no no no I know this girl
it's the Sarah gyeong right alright
let's talk about it general story I'm
gonna let you tell the details she says
some very racist things about black
people and then that's cool now and then
they're relating her keep the jobs they
were letting her keep the job but then
this is new news accordian or chinese a
quarter she looks Chinese so what some
of her tweets that surfaced so here I
was equated Trump's to Hitler before it
was cool oh man it's kind of sick how
much joy I get out of being cruel to old
white men she said worship tonight I
opened my mouth to politely greet a
Republican but nothing but an unending
cascade of vomit flows from my face
hashtag cancel white people white people
have stopped breeding you'll all go
extinct soon this was my plan all along
I saw I didn't hear at times keeper
there pretty much thing maybe that one's
worse read the bottom one that's the
word that's pretty bad our white people
are genetically predisposed to burn
faster in the Sun thus logically being
only fit to live underground like
groveling cross cross that Godwin's dam
but cuz that's so funny cuz that could
actually be a pretty funny joke yeah
really poorly yeah you know especially
what their chocolate yeah just no humor
and anything what's our bit yeah I'm
always looking for the bit yeah I was
like that could have been a funny Josh a
white people so much uh so what she said
in defense
my favorite new source is Facebook no so
she said this hi all I have a statement
about the tweets that have been going
around and then she screenshot some
comments that she's gotten so on top of
it it says as a woman of color on the
internet I have faced torrents of online
hate often along this vein and then
people are writing to her saying at
Sarah Jones if I saw you I would just
like I'd be dog eating goop done she
says at the bottom I engaged in what I
thought of at the time as counter
trolling while it was as satire I deeply
regret that I mimicked the language of
my harassers these comments were not
aimed at a general audience because
general audiences do not engage in
harassment campaign
you should have tagged the mother [ __ ]
you're talking to their special getting
attacked manner so they get attacked and
they just spew out stuff to the side
pops up it's called subtweeting
subtweeting what is that it's basically
like you respond how you feel about a
certain person you say at their names
that's so I feel like everyone did this
[ __ ] like in high school though but it's
supposed to you're supposed to grow out
of it you know yeah well these are from
2014 and because if you don't tag
someone specific it sounds like you're
you're it's for all white people all the
people that you hate so it just sounds
like she hates white people like crazy
when she frames like that I could
understand this I owe cuz because in
that area it's like you always hear the
opposite so it's like she's doing the
opposite well how does it feel if it
does goes the other way she's also
framing it like that now that she could
get fired from her job now not now I'm
not sure so who the [ __ ] knows what she
has for whatever in high school if some
dude said some [ __ ] like like let's see
a black guy said some Asian joke I would
have said some black joke
or whatever like gone back and forth you
would go directly to him instead of
going to like the black part of the
school and just randomly spraying it
yeah and yelling with what she did yeah
yeah cuz it's on Twitter but that's
that's basically what it is but what I'm
saying is like now I won't
I won't talk back as a group I'd make
fun of the individual you don't I'm
saying like so if someone were to be
racist right like let's say some dude
was [ __ ] and call him achieve this
and that like I probably directly make
fun of this person's ugly face or
whatever because if I say something
about like I don't know if the guy's
white and I'm talking [ __ ] about white
people what about like the five other
white bystanders that I just offended
that has nothing to do with this [ __ ]
actions yeah so she wasn't really
effectively trolling because she's
saying white people every time yes I
feel like not to excuse that but
everyone does that like in junior high
or like high school until you learn and
you go oh yeah well I should have just
[ __ ] generalized and talk [ __ ] about
everybody unless it's really funny if
it's funny funny it's okay and except
she's not in July right
and she definitely was never trying to
be a comedian or anything yeah no no
that's the language of Twitter though
that's how everybody is everyone talks
like that on Twitter gets Twitter Turner
goes pretty hard that's why when she
says [ __ ] like it's like as a woman of
color on the Internet is like dude
everyone gets [ __ ] talked on [ __ ] the
internet period yeah you're on the
internet you're getting [ __ ] talked on
the inner even even women of non-color
gets get [ __ ] talked everybody everybody
dude welcome to the Internet yeah that's
the price you pay for being on the
internet at all yeah so the time that
they have said that they are standing by
her despite all of this and that they
have had candid conversations with her
and that
she the reason why she responded this
way was like how she said she was just
imitating the rhetoric of her harassers
and and there's always gonna be trolls
to like that like there they could be
minorities that are pretending to be
wide they could be white people
pretending to be minorities with fake
accounts and all that [ __ ] just to [ __ ]
with you like you can't trust anybody on
Twitter unless they have their [ __ ]
full name their picture and everything
and then you could look them up and know
that they're real and you can get some
dirt on them I'm just tired of everybody
getting fired for [ __ ] they tweeted or
whatever the [ __ ] yeah that's not right
I hate that [ __ ] it's like I don't care
like people losing their jobs and [ __ ]
because they tweeted some stupid [ __ ]
like five years ago I don't like any of
I think there should be like a statute
of limitation yeah like I say like if
you tweeted something past like a year
ago
you're okay like this James Gunn [ __ ]
man yeah he was clearly like I mean look
whatever you want to say about it he was
trying to do bits like he was trying to
joke with with those tweets like about
about kids it's like or whatever like
I've seen worse like at parties that
I've had where people are playing cards
against humanity' right really
oh baby like with the [ __ ] in my
butthole or whatever I've seen all kinds
of stupid dumb [ __ ] like it played in
that game and it's like cards against
humanity' humor is what he was
attempting yeah like but he loses his
job now he can't direct the third
guardians of the galaxy movie it's like
okay like first of all I shouldn't like
you shouldn't drag someone for something
that they said years and years and years
ago especially if they've grown and
changed as a person because no one say
the same all easier that's one thing
yeah you're [ __ ] stupid if you don't
change right another if you don't cringe
at your old [ __ ] - definitely I even
could get my old pictures from like a
year ago
sang my own captions like I believe it
but I'm gonna leave it there cuz I'm
real that's bug when I see myself in a
shirt that doesn't look like a dad shirt
I'm like nah dude your [ __ ] dad
clothes out bud
are you doing yeah another point that
people bringing up with this whole
situation is that it's kind of
interesting how all these other people
they have been white that they've been
getting fired for [ __ ] that they've said
but then this this woman who is Asian
she's not a white woman and now she gets
kind of a pass so and then people are
like well is that really fair
well maybe new york times just evolving
maybe people are starting to evolve and
it does it is it does suck and it can
seem unfair for all the people that got
the [ __ ] end of the stick but I do like
that if companies are taking this
approach whether like there is a statute
of limitations I think that's pretty
dope yeah if this is gonna be the new
standard now like because this happened
in Hollywood and and the stuff before
where you know like in the past they
didn't want people with like their own
YouTube channels or whatever to be on a
movie or anything because they saw it as
competition and then like standards will
change and they'll start to learn the
bracelet or whatever or in this case it
might that might not be an equal
comparison but it's like things will
change with society and technology and
everybody having different standards
right like so if this case was the first
to go oh we're actually gonna stand by
our employees we're gonna be like hey
Sarah
you're good with us we're gonna [ __ ]
back your ass up I know you don't like
you don't like [ __ ] white people but
you're different now
you know they might change like and they
might surface some other [ __ ] and then
it was like some dude said some crazy
gay jokes or whatever but they're like
you know what he's gonna stay our editor
we don't give up it's weird because I
think like people don't want to accept
the fact too that there is like in this
country specifically there's like a
certain like level of hate speech that
means more than something else you know
I mean people they don't want it but
that's not how it is
so for example if she said something
about like the black community for sure
she wouldn't come over umbrella well
that's not fair
I'm not saying what's fair wrong but you
can't just deny the fact that in this
country yeah because of its history
there is a lovelyz' of the red zone and
there's a rather zone of things that you
saw that's true like
black jokes are worse than white jokes
oh for sure and that's just because
they're the history of this country you
know I mean in just everything that's
happened what's going on in the world my
friend it's like [ __ ] nuts yeah so
it's like you know for a lot of people
they like well that's not fair well
there's a lot of things that aren't fair
but there's things that you just can't
did not yeah you know so it's like if
she definitely said something into that
effect about the black community that's
true yeah it's weird because it's like I
agree with that I agree with her being
gone like like in in a way like for what
you're saying but I don't want people to
be fired for saying dumb [ __ ] I just
don't want that okay I just am sick of
the trend yeah like it's like I guess
like for me it's more like you let's see
I add a company right and there was
somebody that was working and I found
out seven years ago he says something
highly racist against Asian people I'm
like he works really good in the
vacations I'll keep it up he hasn't even
done any of that [ __ ] in the office
doesn't do it now so I'm pretty much
okay what was it original or was it just
another dog eating joke no dog eating
joke maybe he's fired
it's not funny I think I fired him funny
what the [ __ ] is anybody it wasn't funny
I'm like dude that hurt my feelings but
it was so funny I gotta keep you in love
funny racist joke I bet you would just
be here she'll be so confused as I can't
come he'll kill me really this is funny
come on you're fired yeah I didn't mean
I didn't say you're a racist I think
that's the worst joke ever but I'm
saying it's not kindergarten anymore
okay you're gonna evolve your humor a
little pack your [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out I
would give him three more chances to
give me a racist joke
and if he makes me laugh and he gets to
keep it oh that's oh it's like an open
mic night you could roast me three more
times right now that's if you make me
laugh you get to keep dude that's really
good your care mentioned dog eating
[Laughter]
all right so uh cat eating oh yes I know
he's like nope mouth if I go down no no
sorry
[Music]
[Music]
you